Let's start the introduction. All right. Welcome
to the DDPS seminar everyone. Before we introduce
our speaker today, let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk. But if you have questions,
you can unmute and ask questions. Were used
chatroom to post your questions so that we can
address them in a q&a session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to external audience.
Therefore, no classified discussion is allowed.
So please watch out. Finally, the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel. Okay, let me now briefly introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to host Dr. Fabian
Gianpaolo, who is a research fellow in Computer
Science and Artificial Intelligence and a member
of the modal research group at the University of
maple that Rico to where he received his PhD in
the mathematics and applications member of the
editorial board of the journal neural computing
and applications and he published by a published
by Springer, and he has co authored articles in
international journals and conference papers on
both applicative and methodological research in
the deep learning field is research interests
include machine learning and deep learning with
a particular focus on exploring the dynamics of
learning these explorations and compasses a wide
range of topics including the development
of innovative neural network architectures,
the investigation on new learning algorithms,
efficiency and the application of these
methodologies to solve complex real world
problems. Today, Dr. Jian power will talk about
learning paradigms for neural networks and the
locally back propagated both for the algorithms.
Please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk from him. Now,
let me ask a questions to our speaker
just to make this stays somewhat informal.
Is it okay? Yeah, of course. All
right. Awesome. So we usually do that.
Okay.
Obviously, you're passionate
about the deep learning, what
would you share with us the
moment when you realize that
you need you want to dive into this community?
Yeah, this is a good question. You know, I was
one of those kids that was always
in front of his computer, you know,
trying to code and some, something like that.
So, when I found out that in the department,
I was a, that was a research group
dealing with this kind of topics,
and in particular, on how machine can learn.
No, I was very fascinated by by by this. So
I asked them to work with them,
I started to work with them.
And so that's how that's why I ended up
where I am now. Awesome. Awesome. Well,
these days you you probably are more
fascinated, fascinated by what they can do.
All right, the stage is yours. Okay.
I will share my presentation. So
can you see the presentation by now? Yeah, yeah,
but it's not worse. Okay. Can make it for
Is it now? Yeah, it is. Okay, here. I will
of course have. Good morning everyone.
First of all, I would like to thank again
Jung Soo and the organizers for giving
me the opportunity to hold the seminar.
As you also say, they probably
jump out there is a fellow at
the University of Naples political Sagunto
and a member of the model reduction group.
This is a brief outline on what we are going
to discuss today we will start by introducing
briefly some basic concepts on neural networks.
The way a neural network cities is tailored
to a specific task and some fundamental
concepts around the learning process. Then,
we will move on to some manipulation,
some experiments about the manipulation
of the learning dynamics. And we will end the
presentation by discussing some applications
of the main ideas we developed in
the field of federated learning.
I think the audience is familiar with the concepts
shown here. So I will just introduce them very,
very briefly. We know that the neuron is
the foundation of computational unit, which
sholden neural networks are built and we also know
that it can be seen as a two step process first,
the input undergo a weighted sum,
which is also added the other term.
And then the result of this sum is processed
through a usually nonlinear transformation
here denoted as lambda, which is
the activity stream function. So,
a deep network can be seen as a stack
of straight up the layers in which the
neurons are read. And from a general
perspective, it can be imagined as
as composed by three main segments.
Now, the input layer which ingest data,
the layers that work together
to extract complex patterns from
data and to provide the functional
representation for these patterns.
And then the output data that provides
the output that aligns with the task we're
dealing with it should be underlined that
some theoretical results exist about this,
this kind of structure says in particular
about the approximation power of these kinds
of structures, as in particular demonstrated by
the universal approximation theorems. Usually,
these results concern that the approximation
capabilities of a feed forward neural network
consists of the continuous functions and the
approximation is with respect to the compact
convergence topology. However, despite the
importance results like this one have from a
mathematical perspective in the
formulation of a neural network,
they come with a measure of concern somehow,
they do not provide a construction rule for
the weights the for the synapses for
the connections of these networks.
So, in this scenario, we may say that the deep
learning problem the learning problem can be seen
as the problem of learning the connection weights
of a large computational graph. But in order to
address this task, we must introduce another basic
yet fundamental concept in the learning framework,
which is loss function. This function
basically measures the discrepancy
between the models predictions and the target
values and can be formalized as reported here,
it's worth noticing that we may see that the
loss function somehow encapsulates the the
objective of the task by measuring the models
deviations from this objective and the in his
lie the reported the general formulation for a
loss function with also some desired properties,
which are actually not always fulfilled.
And with the concept of loss function,
we can reframe the learning
problem as an optimization problem,
which deals with the loss function in this in this
framework, our task is to find a set of weights
that minimizes the loss function. So, considering
a network made up of N units, we should find
the learning routes somehow know a way to adjust
weights in such a way this condition is is fulfill
the condition reported the partial derivative of
the loss function with respect to the variations
the variation of all the all the weights in any
critical point, it is peculiar to notice that
even if the research on this topic has been huge,
somehow only few algorithms have been proposed to
do that. And with reference to table we may also
notice that all the familiar learning rules,
we are used to somehow can be seen as a special
cases or operations of the two main learning rules
which are the IBM one and the backpropagation one
which are different in their essence. However,
in this framework, another important
question that arises and that is to
say what characteristics should learning rules
have to guarantee an efficient learning process
following what we say we should require that
learning rules depend on variables that are
locally available as shown here. For example, on
variables that could be the presynaptic activity,
the postsynaptic activity and the weights itself.
Then, we must notice here that the targets will
be considered the local only for the output layer
of the network. If we stop here, we obtain
what we call the deep local learning,
which of course, basically by applying
these two learning rules layer by layer
from the input one to output one. However,
it could be can be demonstrated that in this
framework for a network it is impossible
to learn optimally a complex function and
in order to address this, we must
require that some sort of input
Information is
propagated from the from the targets to the
internal weights of the architecture. And this is
what happens in what we call local deep learning
in which the generic learning rule is modified by
adding the dependence on some sort of information
that trust versus the network and arrives to the
to the deep wait. Moreover, we can also require
that this information comes in a simplified
version somehow, for example, depending on on the
postsynaptic activities, and in this case, we can
obtain the formulation for the learning rule as
reported in equation three, which can be proven
to be equivalent equivalent to a local supervised
rule in which the targets is directly related
to the to the to the weight. And why is this
important because backpropagation for example,
works just like that. So let's for a moment focus
on the backpropagation. I think that also there's
this process is well known here, but I will
discuss it very very, very briefly. We know
that the backpropagation is the standard way
neural network is streaming basically. And it
can it can be imagine that as a two step process
to two paths process the forward in the forward
pass as the information process layers, it is
transformed by the weights in the activation
function. So which computational unit and
in this way, the model is able to produce
a prediction that can be compared with the
expected target value. So we can measure the
distance between these two quantities. In the
backward pass the information about this error
is propagated backwards through the network
by applying the chain rule of calculus to the
composite function of the loss into the operation
performed the operations performed by the layers
of the network. And this is reported in this three
equation basically, in which we can see how the
error computed on the last layer of network is
transmitted to the generic internal weighed by
the recurrence factor in which is obtained by
applying the chain rule to the generic feed
forward the formulation and in the whole training
process. These two steps are iteratively performed
until we reach meaning for the loss function
or you rate until we met a stopping criteria.
We can also reconnect the backpropagation
with the concept of local deep local deep
learning by considering the learning rule in a
multiplicative form in which appears the target
now recalling the what is the learning rule
for the backpropagation which is basically the
wishbone six here, through some straightforward
manipulations, we can obtain the formulation for
these target t in terms of the back propagated
error. And notice that here we use the simplified
form of information I have i Since backpropagation
shows that it is possible actually to deliver the
same information to all the synapses connected
to impinging to the same neuron. In this context,
we can also write down a general formulation for
this learning rule with backpropagation being a
special case, in which can we can notice that
the information depends on the targets on the
output and all on all the upper layers of
the network and all the upper derivatives.
By the way, there is a reason why the back
propagation is so efficient and then so widely
used, if we perform a Taylor expansion
of the error function around the genetic
weight and also considering more fluctuation
that product view, we can somehow estimate
the effectiveness of the information transmitted
to the points to first order approximation,
we can see that the information that is sent back
to the weights can be interpreted in terms of how
well it approximates the gradient G and since
the most thorough information about the gradient
is contained in its direction, estimation of
a word here, we hold the O returns a measure
more or less of how good is the corresponding the
corresponding optimization optimal decision step
together with radiant information, we
can also estimate some other quantities,
which basically deal with the efficiency
of the transmission of this information.
A very interesting discussion about
this topic is in a work of body and
philosophy from which also this figure is
taken and demonstrate basically, that in
this framework of backpropagation is optimal,
since it achieves both the maximum possible way
Eat information and maximum
possible possible improvement.
Now, despite the optimality of back propagation
and also it's very efficient implementations
from a traditional point of view, the
researcher looking for alternatives to
these learning algorithms have found more
and more space in the community. And one
of the main concern about back propagation
is its biological plausibility. There is no
convincing evidence that biological networks
explicitly propagate rabbit error information
or store neural activities for the subsequent
use in a backward pass or again, the requirement
for such a strict symmetry of the weights across
the learning seems particularly impossible. So,
these considerations with also others
briefly reported there have pushed
the research in this on
this on this topic somehow,
but
also from a practical point of view totally
from a theoretical philosophical summary,
if you want point of view backpropagation shows
some drawbacks, that limited application and in
particular, the need for competent with gradient
of the loss with respect to the real composition
of the layers functions may be difficult to
remain not possible in some in some cases,
the most straightforward example reported here
is the presence of a blackbox inside the model,
unless we are listed inside the
architecture, unless we provide a
differentiable model for this component
derivatives cannot be computed and so,
we cannot apply back propagation. In
this case, of course, we may rely on
different strategies for example, reinforcement
learning or evolutionary algorithm, but often
these alternatives increase computational
demands and are less efficient at scale.
One might wonder, when this limitation when we are
forced to face with this limitation in real cases,
here I report in just few examples, for example,
the integration of AI systems with legacy systems
that own not always but often lacked
interfaces for gradient based learning
or real time dishes and systems in which are
involved with the question Bayes classifier,
so rule b systems are again in in techniques
involving pruning a specification for example,
as a concern that the network
architecture search here
are involved in non differentiable operations
usually like thresholding or masking are probably
in the most interesting context, which is the
integration between the AI systems and humans,
in which here we must consider as inputs
or preferences or qualitative feedbacks,
which are inherently non differentiable and
which may make reading competition, a problem
following the some of these considerations,
in particular, the theoretical ones,
driven by the impossibility of the
backpropagation. In December 2022,
Professor Geoffrey Hinton proposed an
alternative learning learning procedure
called the foot forward algorithm, which replaces
basically the forward pass and backward pass and
back propagation with two footwork passes
one on positive data and the other one on
negative data. And with positive and negative
data, were basically referring to actual data,
real data and wrong data. In this framework, each
layer has its own objective function, who seems
to be simply described as having an Agnes for
positive samples and the low goodness for negative
work. And in particular, the objective of the task
of the learning process is to achieve a luminance
value which is significantly above a certain
threshold, in this case, theta for positive
samples for real data and significantly below that
threshold for negative data. So for example, in a
classification example, and ossification context,
the goal is to accurately toxify an input vector
as positive or negative, with the probability for
an input vector being classified as positive given
by applying the logistic function to the goodness
value minus the threshold. And if we Moreover,
can connect the goodness function with neural
activities, for example, through the norm as
reported here, we can write down the layer
wise loss function as reported in as shown in
equations 1617 MIT. It's interesting to notice
that in this scenario, the weight update rule
becomes in the form reported in the blue box,
in which we can notice that the information on
It depends, only loses its dependence on the
upper derivatives and this somehow
localizes the learning on on the ear.
But how does this learning process behave
in the context of a supervised learning
task? In this slide the report in
the a the behavior of the learning
somehow in the case of classification
task involving the data set analyst,
it's worth underlining that Amnesty is very
well known. And the behavior of simple networks
training through back propagation on this data
sets are all are datasets like, like a nice
well studied in literature. So this
makes a nice very convenient for testing
out new learning strategies to see if they
actually work. However, in this context, for
for the football football algorithm, the
classification is, is done by accumulating
the goodness of all by the first layer for each
label and then taking the label with the highest
accumulated goodness. Now, in general, we know
that deep networks consists of multiple layers,
and we can see that each layer processes its
input to and returns to the subsequently or
what it has extracted, and the network trained by
backpropagation. This allows for an increasingly
complex representation of data since the
learning happens in a year article manners.
For example, in this, in this case, the MR case,
we may see that first layers of the architecture
we extract simpler features, for example, edges,
and the later layers of the same architecture with
struct more complex features, for example, shapes,
but this year article representation of data
basically allows the network to build a robust
representation for the data and to provide
accurate predictions. In the case of the Pew
for football algorithm instead, it can be said
that each layer returns measures of consistency
between the sample and the target. And this can
be seen from a figure I reported year in which
is shown the normal neural activities for all the
layers with respect to the association between the
sample seven and all the possible targets from
zero to nine. And we can see that in this case,
the learning somehow flows through the network
sensor, each layer receives no feedback,
what's happening in the later parts of the of
the structure the structure. And this obviously
impacts the overall convergence process. The
figure on the on the left to here report the error
provided by the layers 123 and the stack calculate
the cumulative error provided by the stock, which
goes from one to treat as conservative leaders.
In this case, we can see that for example, layers
two and three do not positively contribute to the
prediction since their marginal contribution is
negative. Basically, the first layers provides a
lower group with respect to the others. And the
same thing can be seen also in the two fingers on
the writer in which are reported the accuracy of
stack of layers of increasing dimension from
one to five from one to 10 and from one to 15.
And we can see that for the datasets and
NIST and fashion and NIST in this case,
and we can see that these three
lines at some point separate
indicating that somehow each layer is less
capable of the preceding layer to understand
how to work with the input to is receiving.
And this leads to two main considerations.
The first is that a neural network trained with
the Pew football football algorithm struggles
in learning collective representations. And
from this follows the fact that the football
formula or method performs with small networks
shallow networks networks mean by few layers.
However, these new learning strategies as
also some peculiarities we are interested in,
for example, since the learning is
somehow local, there is no need for back
propagation in weights update process. And this is
interesting since it allows for example, to insert
in an era architecture, a non differentiable
black box, I'm going to show potential block
components without impacting the whole training
procedure. Moreover, we know that each layer
directly contribute to the prediction process. And
this is also interesting if we think for example,
about the importance of ensembles methodologies
in the field of machine learning. So we did
idea of enhancing the efficacy of
the football football algorithm,
we developed a methodology whose basic idea
is to split a neural network in blocks,
then applying it back propagation inside
the each block back training each one of
the blocks according to a full portfolio
strategy. As watermark here involves the
third consideration since no error
information is propagated backwards,
we can say that the first layer of the network
somehow will be optimized sooner with respect
to the other layers of the same architecture.
But we will discuss this point in few slides.
In order to make our approach even more efficient,
basically.
Basically, the split the strategy has
been formalized as reported in this slide,
we can see that the generic neural network can
be partitioned in capital K in overlapping sub
networks. And that the fall of the wake
update process follows a back propagation
approach inside each sub networks, where the
error that is propagated backwards depends on
the witness function evaluated on the last
layer of the of the, of the block network,
it's worth not seeing that in this context,
except for the first one of the blocks whose
input is simply the data we have for each one of
the blocks the input will be the output of the
preceding block. So, we are preserving
the general feed forward architecture.
Now, in neural networks trained with
backpropagation, we know the that
all the layers interact collaborate
to minimize the loss function. So,
we may say that each internal layer is
loss function, which is computed on the
last layer with the results of the last
layer. So, we may say that in the back
propagation process, each internal layer of
the architecture is optimized in the sense
in the sense of giving a good embedding
to the to the subsequent layers,
but this factor in our approach means that
internal layers of the blocks
will not contribute to the to
the prediction process and this is
basically what we are seeing here
from this figure in which cannot we can
observe that while four layers 247 and 19.
While these layers fulfill the condition the
goodness condition somehow internally years of
the of the network, do not know how to
how to fulfill the prediction task No.
And
given that sensor, we wanted to push on one side
the layer interaction but on the other side,
we wanted to preserve the layer
West prediction contribution,
we developed a randomized partitioning
strategy with basically consists in
fixing the number of the block of the
blocks in which the network is split,
but varying things randomly varying at iFixit the
number of epochs their sides their extreme and
this guarantees that more or less during training,
all the layers will undergo the the optimization
criterion dictated by the witness function. So
preserving the characteristic we are interested
in here, we can observe how the random the random
reorganization of the of the blocks impacts the
learning pattern, someone who recovering the
latest prediction contribution it can be seen from
the last image here on the on the on the right. Of
course, in this scenario, two main questions arise
if the interaction between
layers is actually improved,
and if we obtain a better convergence pattern
of the entire network, and this second questions
arises from the consideration that now the layers
are optimized also, in the sense of giving a good
embedding to the subsequent layers. So we expect a
more coherent learning pattern across the network.
And in particular, in this slide,
we can observe that actually,
the random mirror organization works somehow as
expected. We can see that the three lines that
I've discussed before now, for example,
in the case of Emily's dataset collapse,
but also in the case of fashion,
m&s dataset, even if they
still separate at some point,
the pattern of convergence is
much more coherent is smoother somehow.
And another thing that we can notice is
that the overall accuracy is here
in terms of error is is improved.
Of course, this proposal strategy
introduces two other hyper parameters,
that is to say the number of the blocks
in which the network is split, and
the epochs for the random to wait until
the random reorganization fixing this
last parameter to fiber we can see on the left
that actually reducing the number of the blocks
stabilizes the convergence while increasing
the number of the blocks returns a convergence
pattern this time in terms of accuracy
much more similar to the pure football
football which is the blue line and
this is explainable by the fact that
if the network is fragmented information
about the layer interaction struggle in
transversing the local network so, we have
a behavior like in in football football the
algorithm 10 blocks means two layers per block
basically, on the other side, we can see that
increasing the frequency for the round number
the organization stabilizes and accelerate the
convergence in this case, while decreasing this
frequency produces a slower convergence behavior.
And this is explainable by the fact that if we
fix a block for a considerable number of epochs,
back propagation will saturate somehow with the
optimization of the last of the block on the last
layer of the block in terms of witness function,
while not minimizing the internal layers of the
block in this sense. So, patterns just
like for example, this staircase appear,
which is in the case of the we are dealing
with 25 epochs wait until we're efficient and
there was this staircase pattern pattern
appear. By the way in in both the cases,
we can observe that the overall of
convergence overall accuracy is incremented.
And this somehow shows that the presence
of that propagated blocks somehow pushes
the layer interaction and leads to a more
coherent behavior during the training.
This is basically a tweak some kind of
a tweak or we develop the exploiting
the third characteristic I
discussed before we wanted to
Hance the efficiency, the efficiency
of the learning process. And so we
exploit it to the sequential refinement of
the learning procedure, the fact that firstly,
or something architecture will be
optimized sooner with respect to
the later layers of the same architecture
from the foot forward. And we did this by
assigning to each layer a probability to be
trained from from a key square distribution.
And so the generic block in this in this
framework will undergo your musician process,
according to probability given by the
probabilities of its constitutive blocks
constitutively sorry,
in this, in this scenario, we also
observed the loss function of the first
of the three node blocks and if it reaches
a steady state, if it reaches a plateau,
the parameter phi over the square distribution
is incremented. In such a way we redistribute
the probabilities in favor of the later
layers of the of the architecture.
Of course, all these after an initial
global training of the network.
And we found out that while this trick somehow
does not impact very much the convergence,
it impacts the computation of times, we wanted
to produce a more efficient learning procedure
with respect to the forward forward so
we evaluated the computation of times
variable on the left on the right we can
see what happens without the random train.
And we can see here that the frequency of
the random organization does not impact
the competition of times while the number
of the blocks does, but this is quite top
uses. Since we know that the back propagation
is very efficient also from a computational
point of view. So the more delay years in a in
a block, the less competition time somehow. On
the right we can see that both the input the
situations, the random training farther away
uses
this quantity,
almost having the computation
of time per epoch with respect
to the football football. So, we
developed basically a strategy that
makes this learning process
even more efficient and so,
somehow widely usable in real
contexts and experimental models.
And given the good results of the lovely
back propagating the foot forward,
we tried also to develop some applications
based on its fundamental ideas, in particular
in the field of federated learning,
what is federated learning briefly, we know that
conventionally I am audits are typically trained
on single data sets located on a single machine
and this requires the data to be aggregated,
but it is not always feasible possible
to centralize data. And reasons can vary
from legal to confidential. So, the federated
learning approach is the federated learning
is an approach is a paralegal where multiple
entities could clients collaborate in solving
machine learning problem under the restriction
of a central server, and all these while keeping
their datasets localized. So this paradigm
shifts the traditional centralized model
training to more distributed approach, which
preserves data privacy in allows to hadir to
legal and confidentiality constraints.
Of course, this decentralized approach
is interesting in a plethora of fields, but in
particular, where the privacy is a is pricked
constraint, for example, in fields like healthcare
or military, military research, but it also pushes
the boundaries somehow of the distributed
computation for machine and deep learning.
Since it allows the model training to be conducted
only on a large scale by distributing the
computational load across multiple nodes.
And this is particularly interesting in
situations where excess extensive simulations
are required, for example, climate modeling,
or large scale, industrial precious, but
how does the training of the local and the
global model covering the typical federated
learning in the digital learning setting
in general, the server initializes, the
weights for a global model in a random way,
the levers, this weights to the clients that
perform some local training on their datasets,
and then send back the information about
weights updates to the server that targets
these information and updates the global
Moodle and this can be done that the exchange
of information about the weights update can
be done by person meeting the gradients or
transmitting the weights in each training
epoch for the local clients as for example,
in fact SGD or waiting for some learning on the on
the clients and then send him back these weights
as in fed ABG. And it's important to notice
that the second approach is usually preferred,
since it reduces the communication frequency
and so, the load for the communication channel
of course, this product comes with its own set of
challenges in among them probably one
of the most important one concern the
the mightiness of data which basically
refers to different data distributions
across the continents. This can
manifest in several forms that
I briefly report in here, but probably the most,
the most common one and is the label distribution
skew in which there is a a very different
distributions very different there are very
different distributions of the label across
the various clients and addressing this set of
challenges. These these issues is important,
since the it can these issues may lead to
inconsistent model updates and degraded
global performances of the model. In particular
are well known issue related to the muddiness is
the Moodle divergence, which consists basically
in the local Moodle, local models becoming very
different from charters. And this causes a problem
when the server aggregates this model so in order
to obtain the global global model, moreover,
over multiple communication rounds, this disk
few branches may accumulate so causing
the global Moodle to diverge and of course
negatively impacting the performances
or of the whole training process.
Another challenge important challenge in this
field is what we call device heterogeneity,
which refers to different hardware
capabilities among the clients.
We know that in typical federated
learning paralegals, the paralegal
uniform other structures are required across
client, but this may limit the fullest utilization
of the computational power, we can think for
example, a client that is less capable it is
less powerful than the others which may become
a straggler slowing down. So the entire training
procedure. Moreover, the visitor agility may
also introduce uncertainty instability. Since,
for example, a device with the limited storage
capability may struggle in handling large model
updates, so causing the causing it to depart from
the training procedure or send incomplete updates.
Of course, several solutions have been proposed
to face these two challenges and in particular,
on one side as a concern on a DNS. Usually
techniques involve the introduction of
some regularization terms, which forces the
weight to not diverge, or in weighting terms
related to data distributions. That's concerned
diversity region it some strategies rely on
client selection, but this may introduce
biases, if not all the clients equally
participate to the training process, or
on split learning which arise privacy
concerns due to common communication of the
of the gradients of gradients information.
So in this scenario, and in particular,
in order to address the challenge or the
data origin it with spike into the idea
of splitting a neural network in blocks
from the local effect propagated forward in the
context of federated learning. These strategies,
this strategy allows us to train different pieces
of off have a global model on different clients,
according to some, some rule, which for
example, can depend on the computational
capabilities of the client. And this is what is
briefly described. In this slide, we basically
imagine that each client receives receives a
partial replica of the global model consisting
in a subset of the blocks in which the global
model is split, perform the training on these
blocks and then send the weights to the to server
the aggregates, these weights in order to obtain
the global model. And this here is reported for
this operation here is described as for example,
a an average simple average. But this is not
a strict constraint in sense that here we can
use all the aggregation techniques from the
federated learning field in this made these,
this technique this approach widely usable.
In this context, of course, we must recall
two important facts. That is to say that
the output of the generic block also serves
as input for the for the subsequent block,
we are in our fifth full word context, and
that the optimization of the generic block
is somehow aware of what's happening before
in network but not in the subsequent parts of
the same network. And this implies
that the partial replicas of the
of the global Moodle delivery to the client
must start from its first block. And this
means that according of course, to the settings
of the of the federated learning procedure, but
there's the possibility that the last few blocks
of the global Moodle could remain on tree. So
in order to overcome this issue, we explored the
sequential refinement of the learning by observing
the difference for each generic communication
around the difference between the weights of
the trained local model, the weight of a block
of course, of the train of a trained local model
and the weights of the global model refers to
the block at the previous communication round,
which is basically the quantity have reported
in this in this slide. And if this quantity
approaches to zero for the majority of the
clients, this block is frozen is excluded from the
The training and the structures of
the partial replica of the global
Moodle delivery to the clients are modified
accordingly as reported in this blue box,
basically, and this is important, if we
consider that in this way, all the blocks
over the global model will be trained by all
the clients involved in this procedure. And
this is of primary importance since we talked
before about the neediness of data. So considering
that each client as its own data set, which
may be different from the the other data sets
of the other clients. And this is basically a
graphical representation of what I just said,
we can see that in the first communication round,
the server delivers to the model to the client
sorry, the batch of replicas of the Moodle
at some point in the training, if the first
block reaches a steady state from a training
point of view, it is frozen it is blocked,
and the structure of the of the Bastion modals is
modified adding another block. What's important
to notice here is that even if the first block,
although Frozen is still delivered to the client,
because it is needed for the fifth full
word learning. Since there is no ongoing
optimization on this block, it will not
require intensive computational resources.
And the methodology of our clients so far has been
tested using the parallel printing
multiple clients in particular 10
Using this aggregation techniques, both for the
VG and for the products, we are benchmarking our
method. So we are using techniques were known
in the field of federated learning. And we also
simulated the effect of non Idina. So data
through these Dirichlet distribution whose
parameter beta basically represent
the level of Skewness in the data,
there's one like marker has to be done
near usually in real monetary scenarios,
typical values of beta spawns the
interval of 0.51. In this case,
we also tested beta 0.3 and 0.1 in order to
to find out how our algorithm perform also in
some sort of extreme scenarios. And these are
basically the results we obtained as beta varies,
we can see a compare those. So with the IID case,
in this case, we can see that performances are
good and consistent, unless beta becomes 0.1,
where a drop in the accuracy can be observed,
but it is somehow expected since 0.1 is means
very different distributions of data
into risk of modal modal the modal
divergences are discussing before,
what's what is not reported here,
but it is important that is that these
results are in line with the ones
that can be found in literature, meaning that this
idea of splitting the neural network in blocks and
then training, the blocks from different clients
actually works and reaches the same levels of
accuracy of other more standard strategies. We
also conducted some experiments involving the
number of the clients in particular we fixed it
by beta to 0.5. And we let the number of clients
vary between five and 50. And in this case, we
can observe more or less the same instance that
for a reasonable number of clients from
five to 20, the performances are quite good.
There is a drop in the accuracies for 50 clients,
but since we're considering beta equals 0.5,
but on 50 clients means that few labels some
quantity will be on on the local data set,
some will decline. So also in this case,
we are we're falling in a weakness
of the federated learning process.
And finally, we tested the
behavior of this approach as
the number of blocks assigned to each client
is varied. And we compare these results with
the case of homogeneous federated learning,
in which all the clients bring all the blocks.
In this case, we can see that the in
this measure, these tests are used
As the as a proxy for measuring the behavior
of the our approach. In the case, for example,
all the clients ever are very have a
very small computational competition,
very small computational power. And in this case,
we can see that in the scenario CMB. Basically,
when some clients train a, all the blocks or
a in a number of blocks, the performances are
very good, we can notice a small drop in the
in the performance is where all the clients
only train a small number of blocks. But also
this is somehow expected since in the in the
procedure that phrase blocks then freeze the first
block add one more block to the training process,
probably some sort of information is loose across
this process. And that's why the performances
are a little worse. But in any case, in
line with with what we say with what we
saw before and also with the case
of homogeneous federated learning.
And this basically concludes this, this
presentation, just a small remark about the
two weeks permanent somehow the locally
back propagate two approaches proposed
the locally back propagated forward and shown
here. Of course, there are experimental setups,
we we needed to understand if these approaches
can actually work. And so we just say
normally, in the case of a classification
task involving two simple data set some nice
temperature on the minister only on fitful word
architectures. Of course, no one experiments
will be extended on different architectures,
different tasks involving more realistic
data sets. And this is a brief list of
the references I used for this tool.
And that's it. I would like to thank
you for your attention. Thank you. Thank
you so much for the wonderful talk. But
let's have a q&a sessions.
If anyone has questions,
please unmute yourself and ask questions.
Have you applied this method to any other data
set? No. No, as I say, just in the in the end
of the presentation. The these were preliminary
investigations, we wanted to understand that if
this kind of a hybrid methodologies between
the football forward and back propagation
actually work
on an experimental setting. So we were taken
out to look at the possible difficulties coming
from different datasets, maybe more realistic
datasets or stranger neural architectures? No.
Now, we know that this kind of hybrid
approaches can be used. Of course, they are not
usable on all the domains on all the networks, but
they have potentialities, in my opinion. And so we
will even investigations about their possible
usage and the limitations. They have some.
Although you haven't applied that,
other than I missed, I missed this. But
you know, basically to the data. Right,
sorry, I didn't get your question. We
use the m&s data and fashion and needs
to which is pretty similar to feminist.
So that's basically two dimensional data.
Exactly, they are using both the cases. So,
there are two dimensional data, right? We
didn't try it with three dimensional
data, like see first 10 For example,
we didn't actually we conducted some
experiments for example on CIFAR. But we
noticed that feed forward network struggle in
reconstructing patterns are suffer due to the
high dimensionality of the of the data. So, we
we should better investigate these aspects or
try the application of this kind
of learning strategies on convolute
other types of net of layers, for
example, convolutional networks,
in this case, convolutional
layers in this case, I see
any like expectations you have
based on the experience on this?
Okay, actually.
I actually after we worked on this
literature
have emerged the some other
manipulation of the football football
of the football football algorithm, which
basically rely on the on the approach
we had that is to say improve the
collaboration of the layers. This
is the probably the main weakness of
this algorithm. And this is what it
has to be pushed to widen the range of
the applicability of this algorithm.
All these to say the thing that someone
has tested these, this algorithm on CNN
is by applying a two step back propagation of
terminate back propagation. I don't exactly
remember the name of the paper, but it is
a very interesting work. So, I think that
these approaches can be extended to
at least two different architectures.
Okay. Thank you. Is there any
other questions from audience?
If you do, please unmute and then ask questions.
If not, well, let's thank our speaker,
Fabio for the wonderful talk and hopefully
through this talk. There will be some
collaboration between Fabio and some
folks at Lawrence Livermore National Lab
or any other folks from the outside. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you very much. And
thank you again for for this opportunity.
Have